the stock market may be collapsing
evergrand is collapsing china won't bail
them out and i am 9.9 million dollars in
debt with the ccp this is breaking news
with coffeezilla
ladies and gentlemen welcome to breaking
news with coffee zella guys we have to
talk about
evergrand evergreen is the chinese
property developer that is on the brink
of collapse why do i care well
apparently they're actually the builder
of the 10 million dollar studio that's
right ladies and gentlemen they own 9.9
million dollars of debt in this building
meaning this may soon be a chinese-owned
youtube channel because evergrand may
soon be liquidating
to xi ji ping
but don't worry if you're worried about
that happening you know changing the way
i report on news that's never going to
happen not even registered cool guy xi
ji ping could ever break my bond of
trust with the zilla stockholders by the
way zilla is down a few points following
the market crash and ladies and
gentlemen if you're watching this right
now you're either in one of two camps
either you have a lot of your money
invested in the stock market the crypto
markets or you have no money if it's the
former congratulations welcome to hell
uh if it's the latter
grab some popcorn because the fireworks
may be just starting now first of all
we know the markets are down right why
the company evergreen now you guys
already know that evergren is a property
developer in china but what you may not
know is it's actually their second
largest and is among the fortune 500
global list this company is massive and
it may be on the brink of collapse due
to growing debt obligations of 300
billion dollars how do they get here
to be honest
i have no idea before i researched this
topic for three minutes on twitter i
thought evergrand was actually the ship
stuck in the suez canal but it turns out
that's the evergreen so not really
equipped to tell you guys what's going
on here but to remedy that i actually
decided to invite on our chief foreign
financial correspondent tom nash to
explain what's really going on tom the
big question on everyone's mind is are
we screwed here uh yes all right thanks
tom what an insightful piece of news so
you heard it here first
we're all screwed
look we know we have to deal with three
or four days of people who don't know
what they're talking about coming on and
talking about contagion all i can tell
you is we wish we had contagion we're
not allowed in our banks are the safest
banks in the world yeah jp morgan can
you um go ahead and cancel those sell
orders on gamestop
yeah
yeah i'm diamond hands down all right uh
back to the story guys sorry about that
um yeah so it looks like
looks like we actually have nothing to
worry about
i sell sell now sell it i'll sell it all
sell it i don't care about people i'm
getting liquidated right now i'm not
getting to work i don't care if i lose
half
maybe the uh expectations of a broad
spread contagion uh it may be overdone
uh you know i think that you know
clearly the impact on growth is is is
there but i think
the key point here is i continue to
believe that the the this is not a a
moment like uh what we had in uh 2008.
yeah on second thought i'm going to need
some bear stearns calls actually no no i
know what i said but there's that
look these are some weak-handed moments
right this is the real test of a good
investor i need bear stearn calls right
now
sorry about that sorry about that ladies
and gentlemen sorry about what a
disaster this first episode of breaking
news with coffeezilla has been i
apologize had to make some
financial calls in the middle of this um
but anyways i hope this has been
enlightening on what's going on with the
evergrand situation don't worry about
the 10 million dollar studio we are in
good hands
say